[Musique]
à première vue la vie semble normal à
colombo capitale commerciale du
sri-lanka al'allure moderne et prospère
mais depuis des mois le pays affronte
une grave crise économique
pour le constater il faut s'éloigner du
centre ville et de ses quartiers chics
selon la banque mondiale plus d'un demi
million de srilankais sont tombées sous
le seuil de pauvreté depuis le début de
la pandémie une situation plus grave que
jamais selon l'équipe de cette ong qui
vient en aide aux populations les plus
vulnérables
ce jour là avec une librairie ambulante
pour des enfants en proie à la
déscolarisation
avec la pandémie il ya eu beaucoup de
pertes d'emplois et ça affecte aussi les
enfants lit à l'inflation les prix de
l'alimentation augmentent les gens
doivent payer l'électricité l'eau et
leur loyer ici ils sont tellement au
pied du mur qu'ils en arrivent à faire
travailler leurs enfants pour survivre
ces familles qui dépendent d'un salaire
journalier sont en première ligne de la
crise actuelle
c'est une facture d'électricité impayés
depuis six mois
s'il paye cette facture ils ne pourront
pas nourrir leurs enfants ils devront
rester le ventre vide a
c'est tout ce que je vais cuisiner pour
5 personnes au prochain repas c'est
vraiment très difficile de livres dans
ces conditions
une grande partie de la population
sri-lankaise a subi de plein fouet
l'impact des restrictions successives et
de la fermeture des frontières liés à la
pandémie tout comme la croissance du
pays priver des revenus liés à
l'exportation et aux visiteurs étrangers
dans l'industrie du tourisme qui
contribuait à plus de 10% du pib
sri-lankais au moins deux cent mille
personnes ont perdu leur emploi du jour
au lendemain c'est le cas de naveen
pereira chef de cuisine depuis 20 ans il
tente aujourd'hui de se relancer tant
bien que mal dans un secteur très
impactées par la hausse actuelle des
prix
normalement dans un restaurant nous
avons des menus des brochures des flyers
pour faire notre pub à l'extérieur mais
à peine imprimer les prix ont déjà
augmenté
et des anciens tarifs nous font tourner
à perte c'est vraiment dur car tout les
prix explosent au sri lanka tout
augmente
allez au restaurant c'est plus que du
luxe maintenant même les besoins
essentiels sont devenus un luxe
depuis la réouverture des frontières les
touristes étrangers commencent à revenir
mais les sri lankais ne sont pas au bout
de leurs peines l'inflation des produits
alimentaires qui sévit depuis plusieurs
mois vient d'atteindre le niveau record
de 25 %
la faute à de mauvaises récoltes et
l'incapacité actuelle du pays à financer
des importations par défaut de devises
étrangères en avril dernier le
gouvernement a banni du jour au
lendemain les pesticides importés avant
de faire machine arrière cette mesure
brutale a fortement impacté la
production agricole sri-lankaise très
dépendante des produits chimiques et
fait bondir les prix les gens ne gagne
plus assez pour pouvoir mener une vie
convenable c'est la triste réalité les
gens font des sacrifices ce qu'ils
achetaient 500 grammes de légumes n'en
achète plus que la moitié aujourd'hui
c'est devenu très compliqué maintenant
j'ai fait tenir 5 euros de légumes dans
ce petit sac il n'y a plus grand chose
dans ce sac
avec de fortes dépenses publiques une
croissance faible et une dette
extérieure colossal de 35 milliards de
dollars le sri-lanka aujourd'hui l'un
des taux d'endettement les plus élevés
au monde et depuis que les agences de
notation ont abaissé la note de la dette
souveraine du pays par crainte de
défauts de paiement les caisses de
l'état insulaire sont plus vite que
jamais très implantés dans le pays via
notamment un grand projet portuaire et
des contrats de construction la chine
est l'un des rares pays à encore
soutenir financièrement le sri-lanka la
dette chinoise représente près d'un
quart de la dette totale du pays
lorsqu ils nous prêtent de l'argent il
le lit à des actifs en font en sorte de
le récupérer via des exportations c'est
pour ça que les aides chinoises vont de
pair avec l'arrivée de produits importés
de chine tout le monde veut voir d'abord
l'argent avant de faire affaire avec le
sri lanka
la vraie faillite c'est quand le monde
entier perdre toute confiance en vous
quand plus personne ne veut vous avancer
quoi que ce soit nous faire crédit
alors c'est la fille qui guette et c'est
exactement ce qui est en train d'arriver
au sri lanka en ce moment
au bord de la faillite le sri lanka fait
face à des pénuries de biens essentiels
comme le carburant en sari chauffeur de
toutous qui a du mal à rentrer dans ses
frais
en ce moment c'est dur pour les clients
comme pour nous
parce qu'on doit payer notre essence
plus cher on doit augmenter nos tarifs
en conséquence pour que ça reste un
minimum viable
mais pour les clients ces tarifs sont
trop élevés
c'est un cercle vicieux
avec la nourriture le gaz l'essence plus
cher et moins de clients en sarre
envisage aller travailler à l'étranger
tout ce qu'on gagne on le dépense pour
nos besoins de base c'est vraiment
difficile avec des enfants à charge
donc si je peux je suis prêt à aller
travailler à singapour
comme en sarre un sri lankais sur quatre
déclarent vouloir quitter le pays au
bureau des passeports de colombo les
files d'attentes sont quotidiennes une
émigration économique pour l'instant
encouragée par le gouvernement qui
espère profiter à court terme des
revenus des millions de sri lankais qui
travaillent à l'étranger